[موسيقى]
تتسارع وتيره الاستثمار في مصادر الطاقه
المتجدده في العديد من بلدان العالم من
بينها بلدان عربيه وقد شهدت هذه البلدان
في السنوات الاخيره استثمارات متزايده ما
يجعل من المنطقه العربيه سوقا واعده
بالنسبه الى الشركات الاجنبيه المختصه في
الطاقه الشمسيه وطاقه الرياح وتيره التحول
التدريجي من الوقود الاحفوري الى المصادر
البديله تعززت مع تنام المخاوف المتعلقه
بامن الطاقه وتقلبات الاسعار جراء الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا فكيف تبدو افاق
التحول نحو الطاقه المتجدده في بلادنا
العربيه
وهل تنجح بعض الدول العربيه في كسب الرهان
والتغلب على التحديات التي تواجهها في
مساعيها الراميه الى التقليل من اعتمادها
على مصادر الطاقه الاحفوريه اهلا بكم في
هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم تشهد صناعه الطاقه تغيرا
جذريا مع تسارع التحول التدريجي نحو مصادر
الطاقه المتجدده كبديل لمصادر الطاقه
التقليديه المكلفه والملوثه عن افاق
الاستثمار في مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده
والنظيفه في البلاد العربيه والعقبات
والتحديات التي تحول حتى الان دون
الاستغلال الامثل للبيئه الملائمه في
العديد من دولا لتوليد الطاقات المتجدده
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا هنا في الاستوديو
والدكتور احمد السلايمه عميد الكليه
الجامعيه الوطنيه للتكنولوجيا ومؤسس
برنامج ماجستير الطاقه المتجدده بالجامعه
الاردنيه من جده الدكتور حسين باسي استاذ
هندسه الطاقه المشارك والاستشاري في
الطاقه المتجدده ومعنا من الرباط عزيز
رباح وزير الطاقه والمعادن السابق في
المغرب فاهلا بهم جميعا
التحول الى الطاقه النظيفه والاستثمار
فيها له منافع كثيره بالتاكيد فقد اظهر
تقرير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه المتجدده ان
الاستثمار في مصادر الطاقه المتجدده فعال
من حيث التكلفه ويوفر النمو الاقتصادي
والوظائف واهداف التنميه المستدامه خمسه
اسباب تجعل تسريع التحول الى طاقه النظيفه
امرا مرجحا في العقود المقبله
ترى الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه المتجدده ان
90% من كهرباء العالم يمكن وينبغي ان تولد
من الطاقه المتجدده بحلول عام 2050 وان
مصادر هذه الطاقه متوفره في جميع البلدان
لكن لم يتم استغلالها بالكامل بعد وتقول
الوكاله الدوليه ان توليد الكهرباء من
مصادر الطاقه المتجدده مثل الشمس والرياح
كان الخيار الاقل تكلفه خلال الاعوام
الماضيه من جهه اخرى اشارت دراسه امريكيه
الى انه وبحلول عام 2029 ستكون الكهرباء
المولده من مصادر الطاقه المتجدده في
امريكا الارخص في العالم
وسيساعد ذلك في حمايه البيئه وصحه الانسان
من انبعاثات الغازات الضاره
التحول الى طاقه المتجدده سيؤدي ايضا
لزياده عامه في الوظائف بما يعادل ثلاثه
اضعاف الوظائف المستحدثه في قطاع الوقود
الاحفوري حسب توقعات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه المتجدده وهذا يعني انه يمكن خلق
اكثر من 30 مليون وظيفه في مجالات الطاقه
النظيفه والتقنيه قليله الانبعاثات بحلول
عام 2030 ووفقا للوكاله فان الاستثمار في
مشاريع مصادر الطاقه المتجدده يحقق ارباحا
ضخمه لبساطه تقنيتها وتوفر المواد الاوليه
[موسيقى]
ولهذه الاسباب الخمسه المذكوره قال
فرانشيسكو لكاميرا مدير عام الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه المتجدده ايرينا ان العالم
يجب ان يتحرك بشكل اسرع ويضاعف طموحاته من
الان الى عام 2030 لان الانتقال الى مصادر
الطاقه المتجدده تشكل حلا فعالا ومستداما
للعديد من التحديات التي يواجهها العالم
اليوم
ولهذه الاسباب ايضا تتجه دول عربيه لرفع
استثماراتها في انتاج الطاقه من المصادر
المتجدده حيث خطط بعض الدول خطوات مهمه في
محاوله لخفض الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري
مثل الفحم والنفط والغاز والتقليل كذلك من
مستويات الانبعاث الكربونيه فكيف تبدو
جهود بعض الدول العربيه للتحول نحو
استخدام الطاقه المتجدده لا سيما الطاقه
الشمسيه
تعتزم السعوديه وهي اكبر مصدر للنفط الى
العالم استثمار اكثر من 266 مليار دولار
في قطاع الطاقات النظيفه ما يعد اكبر
استثمار معلن في المنطقه العربيه حتى الان
كما تخطط لبناء واحده من اكبر محطات توليد
الهيدروجين الاخضر في العالم تعمل بسعه
تزيد على اربعه جيجا وات من الطاقه
الشمسيه والرياح ومن المتوقع البدء في
تشغيل تلك المحطه بحلول عام
الامارات تعمل ايضا على التحول نحو الطاقه
النظيفه وتهدف الى توليد 50% من
احتياجاتها من الكهرباء من مصادر متجدده
بحلول عام 2050 وقد دشنت عام 2013 محطه
شمس للطاقه الشمسيه المركزه وتلتها محطات
اخرى مثل محطه نور ابوظبي
الظفره للطاقه الشمسيه الكهروضوئيه سلطنه
عمان دشنت مطلع عام 2022 محطه عبر اثنين
للطاقه الشمسيه بقدره 500
لهدف تزويد نحو 50 الف منزل بالكهرباء وفي
اطار توجهها نحو قطاع الطاقه المتجدده
افتتحت قطر في اكتوبر الماضي محطه الخرسعه
للطاقه الشمسيه كما اعلنت عن مشروع لانشاء
محطتين اضافيتين في مدينتين سيعيد ورسلان
الصناعيتين ومن المتوقع ان يبدا انتاج
الكهرباء من المحطتين نهايه العام المقبل
الاردن اطلق مؤخرا محطه بينونه للطاقه
الشمسيه كاكبر محطه من نوعها في المملكه
بقدره انتاجيه تصل الى 200 ميجا وات وفي
مصدر دشنا مشروع بنبان للطاقه الشمسيه في
محافظه اسوان اواخر عام 2019
وبحسب البيانات الحكوميه فان المحطه ستوفر
الكهرباء لاكثر من مليون منزل في فبراير
2016 اطلق المغرب المرحله الاولى من مجمع
نور ورزازات للطاقه الشمسيه المركزه وتصنف
محطات نور المغربيه وبنبان المصريه ضمن
اضخم محطات الطاقه الشمسيه في العالم
[موسيقى]
دكتور احمد سلامه اهلا وسهلا بك اهلا
وسهلا لماذا كل هذا الحديث في العالم هذه
السنوات على الطاقه المتجدده وضروره
الذهاب اليها تمام يعني عندما ننظر لماذا
نحتاج الى الطاقه المتجدده هناك ثلاث
اسباب رئيسيه السبب الرئيسي الاولاني هو
موضوع بيئي سمعنا كثيرا في موضوع التغيرات
المناخيه الاحتباس الحراري قمم الارض وقمم
المناخ التي حصلت اخر قمه كانت في شرم
الشيخ وقبلها في جلاسكو وقمت باريس واقلع
المختلفه يعني معظم العالم عندما اجتمعوا
قرروا فعلا تخفيض الانبعاثات الكربونيه
الناتجه من حرق الوقود الاحفوري سواء نحكي
نفط او غاز او فحم طبعا هذا الحكي سببه
انه فعلا انه درجه حراره الارض خلال
الخمسين سنه او منذ بدء الثوره الصناعيه
زادت مقدار 1.1 درجه لحد الان اذا بقي
العالم على استخدام الطاقه الاحفوريه في
نفس الوتيره اللي بستخدمها حاليا متوقع ان
فعلا ترتفع الحراره لاكثر من درجتين وهذا
سيؤدي الى ذوبان القطب المتجمد الشمالي
ارتفاع منسوب المياه في البحار غرق العديد
من المدن الساحليه واختفاء العديد من
المدن وما نلاحظه من تغير مناخي من خلال
انه التصحر او اشتداد السقوط الامطار في
بعض المناطق يعود الى موضوع اللي هي طبعا
الاحتباس الحراري الناتج من حرق الوقود
الاحفوري لذلك انه فعلا زعماء العالم كلهم
قرروا انه تقليل الوقود الاحفوري
والاعتماد المتزايد على مصادر الطاقه
المتجدده هذا السبب الاول السبب الثاني
اللي هو سبب اقتصادي احنا لاحظنا بالسنوات
العشر الاخيره خاصه انخفاض اسعار الطاقه
المتجدده وخاصه بعد دخول دوله مثل الصين
على خط تصنيع الخلايا الشمسيه اصبحت
الخلايا الشمسيه اسعارها رخيصه جدا
ومتناول الجميع وبالتالي احيانا فعلا
تركيب محطه الطاقه الشمسيه ارخص من محطه
وقود احفاري والسبب الثالث اللي هو السبب
اللي هو امن التزود الطاقه انا عندما تكون
مصادر الطاقه محليه لا يستطيع اي جهه ان
تمنع الشمس او الرياح من الدخول الى هذه
الدوله وبالتالي انه هناك فعلا توجه عالمي
متزايد لاستخدام الطاقه
اجمالا هل يمكن القول ان الدول العربيه
ماضيه بشكل جدي
في هذه السنوات في هذا في هذا المجال يعني
احدث تحديات امام الطاقه المتجدده هي
الكلفه هناك العديد من الدول العربيه التي
فعلا لديها استطاع ماليه واستطاعه ماديه
لعمل مشاريع طاقه متجدده وفعلا مشت بطريقه
وماشي بطريقه كتير ممتازه هناك بعض الدول
التي قد تكون امكانياتها الماديه اقل
يعني اقل من ذلك ولكن من استطاعت من خلال
وضع تشريعات تسمح للقطاع الخاص بالاستثمار
في مواضيع الطاقه المتجدده من المضي بشكل
جيد حاليا عندنا دول مثلا مصر السعوديه
المغرب الاردن الجزائر دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده
فعلا وباقي دول الخليج انه ماضيه بشكل
كثير ممتاز في مواضيع الطاقه المتجدده
يعني صحيح احنا متوسط او خلينا نحكي نسبه
انتاج الطاقه المتجدده في الدول العربيه
لا تزال اقل من المتوسط العالمي ولكننا
ماشيين في وتيره يعني خلال السنوات
القادمه اتوقع ان نصل الى المتوسط العالم
ونتجاوزه على ذكر هذه الاستثمارات دكتور
حسين باسي السعوديه قد تكون في المقدمه
يعني عندما تضع تقريبا 266 مليار دولار
في مشروع الطاقه المتجدده هل هذا
الاستثمار بهذه الضخامه مضمون
ان ينقل المملكه تدريجيا
للاعتماد على الطاقه المتجدده
طبعا بالنسبه لكلمه الاعتماد على الطاقه
المتجدده احنا عندنا طبعا في خطه
الاستراتيجيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بانه حيكون الاعتماد على الطاقه المتجدده
بنسبه 50% في حلول عام 2030 اليوم سبحان
الله كان في توقيع اتفاقيه بخصوص ثلاثه
مشاريع ضخمه الحقيقه في الطاقه المتجدده
وتحديدا الطاقه الشمسيه بمجموع 4400 او
اربع الاف550 ميجا وات من الطاقه الشمسيه
اخدتها اضخم الشركات مثل شركه اكوا بارك
شركه بديل
وحيعملوا عليها الان ان شاء الله في خلال
الفتره القادمه باذن الله هذه طبعا كانت
اخر المستجدات بخصوص الطاقه المتجدده
بالاضافه الى 700 ميجا اللي هي في منطقه
الجوف المتمثله 400 ميجا من طاقه الرياح
اللي هي في منطقه دومه الجندل وايضا 300
ميجا واط اللي هي في سكاكا فنعم نجد انه
فعلا المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
طريقه ان شاء الله صحيح
لجعل الطاقه المتجدده ضمن مزيج الطاقه
بالاضافه الى الخمسين في الميه الاخرى
طبعا حتكون طاقه نظيفه ولها تفاصيل ان شاء
الله
الفكره انه زي ما تفضل يمكن الدكتور احمد
في بعض
النقاط الاساسيه في الطاقه المتجدده
يعني ايش المتطلبات اللي تحتاج انها تكون
في هذا الجانب هناك ايضا جوانب تقنيه على
سبيل المثال هل الشبكه شبكه الكهرباء
على استعداد بدخول الطاقه المتجدده لها ام
لا معنى اخر احنا نعرف انه الطاقه
المتجدده تختلف عن الطاقه الاحفوريه بحيث
انه بوجود الوقود عندنا فاحنا نقدر نتحكم
في كميه الانتاج في المولدات وبالتالي ضخ
هذه الكميه من الطاقه الى الاحمال
التجاريه والسكنيه والصناعيه
اما بالنسبه للطاقه المتجدده فاحنا لا
نتحكم في هذه المصادر كالشمس احنا لا
نتحكم في حركه الغيوم
لانها المعادله واضحه اذا كان هنالك ضوء
فهنالك طاقه شمسيه نقدر نستفيد منها
وبالتالي نفس الشيء بالنسبه للطاقه الرياح
فهذه المصادر تدعى باللغه الانجليزيه اي
انها لا يمكن التحكم فيها ومن هنا من
الضروري ان تكون شبكه الكهرباء جاهزه
ومستعده لهذا التردد وهذا التغيير في
الظروف الطقس التي تتحكم في عمليه انتاج
الطاقه من هذه الطاقه المتجدده اذا كانت
دول مثل السعوديه السيد عزيزي رباح
بمكانتها النفطيه الرائده في العالم
تسعى للبحث والاستثمار بهذا الشكل في مجال
الطاقه المتجدده فما بالك دول مثل المغرب
او الدول المغرب بشكل عام الجزائر تونس
ليبيا هذه الدول الاخرى هل هي مدعومه اكثر
ربما حتى من الدول الخليجيه للبحث
والاستثمار في هذا المجال
ما اتفق معك انه الدول التي لا تنتج
الطاقه الاحفوريه وتستورد اكثر الفاتوره
الطاقيه في المغرب تصل سنويا الى تسعه
مليار دولار وقد تكون اكثر هذه السنه فهي
مطالبه طبعا بان تنوع مصادر يعني الطاقه
اولا لتحقيق ما يصطلح عليه بالامن الطاقي
والسياده الطاقيه ولكن ايضا من تخفيض هذه
الفاتوره الطاقيه وتخفيض ايضا من
الاستيراد يعني حتى لا يتاثر الميزان
التجاري ولذلك المغرب منذ 2009 يعني اطلق
هذه الاستراتيجيه مثلها مثل جميع الدول
العربيه التي اطلقت فيما بعد يعني
استراتيجيات في مجال يعني التنوع الطاقي
دعني اقول وانا
من خلال من بركهم لابد ان نعرف بانه من
الان الى حدود 2050 يعني سيبقى هناك نوع
من المزيج بين الطاقات الاحفوريه لكن
ستكون نظيفه وهناك التكنولوجيا الان تعد
لهذا لتنظيف بالطاقه وطبعا الطاقات
المتجدده المغرب سار في هذا الاتجاه ودول
اخرى سارت في هذا الاتجاه ربما نحن الان
ندخل في مرحله جديده يعني المرحله الاولى
دعني اقول هي مرحله انطلاق يعني هذه
الاستراتيجيه هذه المرحله الان هي مرحله
ضبط يعني تنزيل هذه الاستراتيجيه اولا من
خلال الانتقال من استعمال الطاقه فقط في
انتاج الكهرباء الى استعمال الطاقات
المتجدده في قطاعه اخرى مثل قطاع النقل
الذي يستهلك حوالي 30% من الفاتوره
الطاقيه من قطاع الصناعه الذي يستهلك
تقريبا حوالي 26% احيانا يصل الى 30% من
قطاع البنايات يعني المنازل والبنايات
التي تستهلك حوالي 22% الى قطاع الفلاحه
الذي يستعمل الغاز الطبيعي والكهرباء الذي
يستهلك حوالي 8% عموما فاذا الان من انتاج
الكهرباء من الطاقات المتجدده الى تعميم
الطاقات المتجدده في قطاعات متعدده طبعا
هذا كله يحتاج الى مؤسسات
يحتاج الى تشريعات يحتاج ايضا الى تشجيع
وتحفيزات جبائيه ضريبيه طبعا يحتاج الى
منظومه ماليه متكامله وايضا وايضا واقولها
هذه مناسبه ان الدول العربيه بامكانها
نظرا لكثره المعادن المتوفره عندها ان
تجلب ما يسمى بالصناعه الطاقيه لا نكتفي
باستهلاك المعدات واستيرادها بل ننتقل الى
مرحله متقدمه وهو الصناعه الطاقيه ولا
سيما ان هناك صراع قوي في العالم الان على
البطاريه على تخزين الطاقه على البطاريات
على السيارات الكهربائيه واعتقد انه
المرحله المقبله ستكون تجويد وتعميم هذه
الطاقه المتجدده في كافه القطاعات ولكن
ايضا جلب استثمارات في مجال الصناعه
الطاقيه من بينها كما قلت المعدات وايضا
الهيدروجين الذي يحتاجه العالم ويمكن ان
يكون بديلا في كثير من القطاعات ان يكون
بديلا للطاقات الاحفوريه عندما نتحدث عن
الطاقه المتجدده دكتور سلامه
دائما نشير الى الشمس والرياح صحيح هل
الدول العربيه
في وضع افضل من من كثير من دول العالم في
هذا المجال يعني مثلا ننتقل الخليجيه
منطقه حاره الشمس تقريبا لا تغيب هل هذا
يجعلها في موقع افضل قدما الوطن العربي
كله يقع ضمن منطقه الحزام الشمسي الحزام
الشمسي التي هي تتمتع باعلى اشعاع شمسي
على مستوى العالم وبالتالي جميعنا سمع قبل
عده سنوات على مشروع جزر تك يعني كانت
الشركات الاوروبيه جميعها تريد ان تستثمر
بانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه من خلال الطاقه
الشمسيه في شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
وتصدير الطاقه الكهربائيه الى اوروبا لانه
انتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه عنا وتصديرها
لاوروبا ارخص من انتاجها في اوروبا طبعا
طبيعه المناخ والطقس مثلا شرعت في في
اتفاقيه مع قبرص ومع اليونان بكعب البحري
لتزويدها
وكانت فعلا حوالي 500 شركه اوروبيه تريد
ان تستثمر يعني مئات المليارات فعلا في
منطقه شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط ولكن
جاء بالجزء الاضطرابات السياسيه في الوطن
العربي وبعد ذلك ضعف ضعف المشروع يعني
الوطن العربي يتميز بهذا الشيء انا حاب
اقرب انه حتى للاخوه المستمعين انه الطاقه
الكهربائيه هل حوالي ثلث الطاقه الكلي
لانه احنا نعرف انه في طاقه تذهب الى
النقل تذهب الى بصراحه الى الصناعه
وبالتالي ما ذكروا الطفل الكريم انه موضوع
انه فعلا احنا كل التركيز حاليا على انتاج
الكهرباء من مصادر الطاقه المتجدده ولكن
نحن الخطوه القادمه وهذه اللي احنا
بنتوقعها ان يتم التوجه نحو النقل وحاليا
انه البرلمان الاوروبي اقر انه بسنه 2030
او 2035 لن يكون هناك سيارات تعمل بالوقود
الاحفوري كلها سوف تكون تعمل على الطاقه
الكهربائيه سيارات كهربائيه ومصدر
الكهرباء لهذه السيارات سوف يكون من
الطاقه مجدده وبالتالي احنا عم ننتقل
تدريجيا انه حتى لمصادر
للنقل لمصادر اخرى لموضوع اللي هي الطاقه
المتجدده ولكن هل هذا ربما احيانا يعرق
التقدم في هذا المجال يعني مثلا دول نفطيه
مثل دول الخليج قد لا تتحمس كثيرا للطاقه
المتجدده لان هذا يعني ان ثروتها الاساسيه
النفطيه او الغاز
سيتراجع الطلب عليها يعني هو انا لا اعتقد
انه تراجع لانه هو عباره عن انه هاي تروه
موجوده والعالم سبق يحتاج الى النفط سيبقى
يحتاج الى الغاز لن يستطيع ان التخلي عنهم
احنا عنا مشكلتنا في موضوع الطاقه
المتجدده وهي احداث تحديات تخزين يعني في
البدايه الانتقال بكون بشكل سريع بالطاقه
المتجدده ولكن بعد ذلك تصبح الشبكه غير
قادره على استيعاب المزيد بصراحه بدون من
الطاقات المتجدده بدون تطوير الشبكه
والاستثمار فيها موضوع التخزين وخاصه اني
انا
الكهرباء احيانا في وقت وانا بحاجه الى
الكهرباء في وقت اخر وبالتالي لا يزال
تقنيه التخزين بصراحه مكلفه مع انه في
السنوات الاخيره نزلت اسعارها ولكن
لا يزال بدها بدها مبالغ واستثمارات كبيره
جدا وموضوع التكنولوجيا اللي تم ذكره
زميلنا كمان من المغرب انه فعلا
التكنولوجيا موجوده لدى الدول الغربيه وهي
حتى انه يصير عنا تطور اكثر احنا بحاجه
انه فعلا انه يكون هناك صناعه في الدول
العربيه لانتاج مثل هذه خلينا نحكي
الاجزاء لمشاريع الطاقه المتجدده اذا
توقفنا دكتور حسين باسي في جده عند
الاسباب الخمسه التي سقناها قبل قليل في
التقرير والتي تجعل تسريع التحول الى
الطاقه النظيفه امر مرجح في العقود
المقبله اشرنا الى انه اقل كلفه هو جيد
للبيئه ارخص طبعا
وزياده في الوظائف
وسيعطي فرصه لارباح
ضخمه من بين هذه المزايا او المحفزات انصح
لنا التعبير ما الذي يدفع اكثر نحو المضيق
قدما
الاصرار على الذهاب الى الطاقه المتجدده
طبعا جميع الاسباب الخمسه التي ذكرت هي
يعني لها اهميتها واهميتها صراحه بتكون
جدا عاليه يعني اقدر اقول لكم يعني ما في
شيء نقدر نقول انه هو اهم من يعني من
الاخرى في الوقت الحالي قد يكون مثلا
عمليه توليد الوظائف هو الاقوى لكن في وقت
اخر ممكن يكون عمليه اللي هو التكلفه
حتكون مثلا ارخص خصوصا زي ما ذكروا
الزملاء والضيوف الكرام بانه التكلفه الان
بتنزل بشكل ملحوظ وهذا فعلا لاحظنا في
العشر السنوات الاخيره في يعني التكلفه
بتنزل بشكل كبير جدا جدا جدا
بالنسبه للوظائف على سبيل المثال مشروع زي
دوله الجندل خلق يعني هذا المشروع لحاله
لا يقل عن 600 وظيفه او اكثر حتى بعض
المشاريع هذه بالنسبه للوظائف قد لا تخلق
وظائف
من الناحيه التشغيليه ولكن من الناحيه
بناء المشاريع بل اذا انتقلنا الى مرحله
التصنيع نجد انه راح تخلق وظائف باعداد
كبيره صراحه والتكنولوجيا يمكن نقلها الى
الدول العربيه حتى نستطيع صناعه هذه
التكنولوجيا ويمكن هذا يقدر نقول فائده
سادسه يمكن نقدر نحطها امامنا وهي انه
نبغى نوصل لمرحله انه هذه التقنيات يمكن
تصنيعها بمعارف بمراكز بحثيه متواجده في
المملكه والمتواجده في الدول العربيه حتى
نقدر نطور هذه المنتجات اللي موجوده عندنا
والحقيقه المراكز البحثيه اللي موجوده
عندنا في الدول العربيه ممتازه جدا واخرجت
نتائج بحثيه قويه جدا كل المطلوب منها
انها هي تنتقل هذه الابحاث من المعامل او
من المراكز البحثيه الى النور من خلال
المصانع ومن خلال الاستفاده منها ومتفائل
بانه هذا الامر راح يحصل بشكل قريب جدا
جدا له هل نحتاج ايضا دكتور باسم الى الى
حمله توعيه شعبيه واسعه لان عندما نتحدث
عن الطاقه المتجدده وهذا حتى هذا النقاش
الذي نقوله الان قد لا يكون بالنسبه
للمواطن العادي امرا سهلا هو تعود على
الطاقه الاحفوريه
وبالتالي من الصعب عليه ان يتكيف مع مثل
هذا الانتقال ولو كان تدريجيا
بالنسبه للمواطنين المواطن العالي يعني كل
ما لديه من اهتمام ان تصل الكهرباء له
بشكل موثوق وبشكل وبجوده عاليه سواء اتت
من طاقه متجدده او اتت من طاقه حوريه قد
يعني يمضي الى موضوع انه يستخدم الطاقه
المتجدده على سطح منزله كالطاقه الشمسيه
او غيره والان الان الانظمه اللي موجوده
اصبحت يعني سهوله انه ممكن اي شخص يركب
يعني انظمه طاقه شمسيه على سطح منزله
فالتوعيه قد تكون يمكن في منظور اخر ليس
من الطاقه المتجدده تحديدا وانما في كفاءه
الطاقه استهلاك الوقود ذكروا للضيوف
الكرام موضوع اللي هو
النقل الان توضع تضع الدول العربيه وراجعت
مؤخرا في احدى المشاريع اللي بعمل عليها
في كفاءه الطاقه بالنسبه للنقل لوائح
واشتراطات جميله جدا تدعو الى تقليل
التكلفه استهلاك الوقود سواء احنا بنتكلم
عن الوقود الاحفوري او حتى اذا انتقلنا
الى السيارات الكهربائيه او الهيدروجينيه
ما زالت مساله الكفاءه مهمه جدا
الكثير من الدول العربيه تبنت موضوع
الاشتراطات في في السيارات وفي غيرها من
المركبات لاستخدام الوقود بشكل افضل هنا
تكمن الحقيقه
موضوع اللي هو الوعي غير ذلك يمكن حيكون
الموضوع
يعني من الجانب الصناعي اكثر من في عمليات
محطات توليد الكهرباء وغيره من حيكون
التركيز في توريد الطاقه من الطاقه
المتجدده حيكون يعني الموضوع اعمق ومعظم
الدول العربيه الان في هذا الجانب تحديدا
بالنسبه اللي يبغى يركبوا الواح شمسيه
مثلا في منازلهم للاستفاده من هذا الجانب
ينتظره الان الاشتراطات واللوائح في هذا
الخصوص والدوله العربيه تمضي قدما في هذا
المجال السيد عزيز رباح وانت تحدثنا من
المغرب الحقيقه لفتا انتباهي راي اعرب عنه
خبير الطاقه الرياح في المغرب السيد سعيد
كاميرا يقول وانا اريد ان تفصل لنا اكثر
لان الفكره الحقيقه تحتاج الى توضيح يقول
الطاقه المتجدده هي اداره قبل ان تكون
استثمارا مما يجعل تحقيق الاهداف اكثر
تعقيدا هل فعلا هناك قضيه اداره وقضيه
حوكمه في اداره هذا الملف اكثر منها قوه
مال واستثمار في التقنيات
اولا
لابد ان اشير ان الحمد لله المغرب فيه
مؤهلات كثيره وكثيره جدا اعتقد ليس فقط
لعقود ولكن لقرون نحن الان نتحدث عن
الطاقه المتجدده في الاراضي المغربيه لكن
لم نتحدث بعد عن ما هو موجود الان في
البحر خاصه بالنسبه للطاقات الريحيه وايضا
حتى للطاقات البحريه فاذا افاق كبيره جدا
في الدول العربيه في المغرب بالخصوص انا
قلت في كلمه انه الطاقات المتجدده ليس
قرار تقني الطاقات المجدده المتجدده هي
استراتيجيه كامله الاركان عندما اطلقت لم
تطلق فقط كقضيه تقنيه يعني تعويض معدات
بمعدات اخرى ولكن اطلقت كنظره مستقبليه
اطلقت كاستراتجيه كقرار سياسي والقرار
السياسي يترجم طبعا على مستوى المؤسسات
فهناك الحكومه التي تضع الاطار وتضع
التشريعات وتضع استراتيجيات ولكن هناك
المؤ المكلفه مثلا هناك الان مؤسسه هي
الوكاله الوطنيه للطاقات المتجدده التي
تعنى بالمشاريع انتاج الكهرباء من الطاقات
المتجدده هناك الشركه الوطنيه للكهرباء
التي تشتري هذه الطاقه المتجدده في اطار
تعاقد مع هذه الوكاله الوطنيه طبعا من
خلال شراكه من القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص
هناك الوكاله الوطنيه للنجاعه الطاقيه او
للكفاءه الطاقيه ثم ايضا هناك مؤسسه اخرى
تعنى بالبحث العلمي تعنى بمجلات اخرى فاذا
هناك نوع من البناء المؤسساتي الذي فعلا
هو مدعوم ايضا
بتشريعات يقع تحينها باستمرار اعطيه على
سبيل المثال اخر اخر قانون في هذا المجال
كيف نسمح للقطاع الخاص ان ينتج الكهرباء
للقطاع الخاص كيف نسمح للمستثمرين ان
ينتجوا الكهرباء للشركات الصناعه على
مسامير المثال مع تحديد طبعا القدره التي
يمكن ان ينشاها هذا كان قانون لكن عدلناه
لكي نسمح لمزيد من الاستثمار والا يبقى
الامر ان يتعلق فقط بالمنظومه الكهربائيه
العموميه يعني الشركات لكن لابد ان نتوجه
الى نوع من الشراكه بين القطاع الخاص
والقطاع الخاص ثم ايضا تم اقرار قانون مهم
جدا وهو كيفيه تمكين كل المواطنين سواء
كانوا في منازلهم او كانوا في مصانعهم او
كانوا في اداراتهم او مؤسساتهم ان ما يسمى
بالانتاج الذاتي للكهرباء فهناك قانون
للانتاج الذاتي للكهرباء الذي يحدد
الاشتراطات يحدد يعني ظروف وشروط يعني هذا
الانتاج ولكن يعطي ايضا الامكانيه ان
الفائض الذي سيبقى عندها هؤلاء المنتجين
الذاتيين يمكن ان يضخى في المنظومه
الكهربائيه طبقا وفق شروط بكل هذا المغرب
الحمد لله اقر ما يسمى بالوكاله الوطنيه
لتقنين الكهرباء والتي ستتحول الى الوكاله
الوطنيه لتقنين يعني وضبط يعني الطاقه لكي
تراقب السوق تراقب التنافسيه بين الشركات
لكي تراقب الاشتراطات التقنيه حتى تكون
اشتراطات موضوعيه يعني يناسب الجميع ثم
ايضا تراقب الشبكه الكهربائيه مع حريه
استعمال هذه الشبكه الكهربائيه من طرف
جميع المنتجين فاذا اعتقد البناء التشريعي
والبناء المؤسساتي والثقه بين القطاع
العام والقطاع الخاص شيء ضروري لكن ليس
هناك كمال في اي عمل سيدي دائما هناك
مراجعات ولذلك دائما هناك تعديلات
للقوانين هناك مراجعه للمؤسسات هناك تغيير
للمسؤولين لكي تكون الحوكمه على احسن ما
يرام وهناك ايضا مؤسسات التي تراقب تراقب
عندما يكون هناك تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء
تتدخل هذه المؤسسات لمعاقبه من لا يلتزم
بالتوجه العام والاستراتيجيه او ربما من
لا تكون حوكومته ضعيفه فلذلك انا متفق معك
لا يكفي الحديث عن الجوانب التقنيه لكن
لابد من بناء متكامل يعني كامل الاركان
كما قلت تشريعي المؤسساتي المراقبه وايضا
الثقه بين القطاع الخاص والقطاع العام هذه
العلاقه بين القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص
الدكتور سلامه كيف يمكن ضبط بايقاع يكون
لمصلحه البلد في النهايه لان اذا تركنا كل
الامر بيد الدوله قد يكونوا اكثر قوه
ماليه ولكن ليس بالضروره اكثر نجاعه في
التسيير وفي الاداره كيف يمكن معالجتها
اذا اردنا استثمارا ناجحا فيجب ان يكون
هناك القطاع الخاص جزء اساسي من هذا
الاستثمار وانا اذا سمحت لي ان اتكلم عن
تجربه الاردن في هذا المجال والاردن نعرف
احنا دوله يعني مصادره خلينا نحكي الماليه
قليله ولكن استطاع حاليا الوصول الى اعلى
النسب بانتاج الطاقه المتجدده بالنسبه
لعدد السكان يعني انا اذا اخذنا احصائيا
العالم يولد كهرباء 60% من مصادر الطاقه
تكون من وقود احفوري واربعين في المئه
تكون
متوزعه بين 15% طاقه هيدرومائيه وتعتبر
طاقه متجدده و15 مئه طاقه شمسيه وطاقه
رياح وطاقات متجدد اخرى و10% طاقه نوويه
يعني الاردن حاليا عنده تقريبا 28% من
كهربته جاي من الطاقه الشمسيه وطاقه رياح
وهذا حتى ضعف المعدل الموجود على مستوى
العالم بالنسبه لطاقه الشمس وطاقه الرياح
كيف وصلنا لهذه النتيجه تم من خلال فعلا
سنه تشريعات تسمح للقطاع الخاص في
الاستثمار في الطاقات المتجدده وفعلا تم
بناء محطات طاقه شمسيه وطاقه رياح في
مناطق متعدده
وفعلا من خلال انه العلاقه بين طبعا
القطاع العام والخاص فانا اتوقع انه فعلا
انه موضوع اشراك القطاع الخاص اشي مهم جدا
لانه المال بيد القطاع الخاص وهم من
يستطيع ان يستثمر ولكن يجب ان تكون هناك
قوانين يعني واضحه قوانين بصراحه تساعد
الاستثمار وتحفظ حق برضو الحق العام في
هذا الموضوع نتحدث عن الاستثمار ولكن
بالنسبه للتقنيات المعتمده هل اذا دخلنا
في هذه التجربه بقوه
سنضطر بالضروره الى اللجوء الى الدول
الغربيه الامريكيه او الصين وغيرها لتاسيس
بنيه تحتيه ناجعه لا يزال لا التكنولوجيا
في ابيض الغرب يعني معظم دولنا العربيه
تستورد هذه التكنولوجيا
التكلفتها يعني في في يعني الغرب يعني اذا
اردنا احنا فعلا نشر الطاقه المتجدد اكثر
فيجب ان يتخلى عن موضوع حقوق الملكيه
الفكريه وان ان يتم ان فعلا السماح للدول
الناميه للدول الاخرى ان تقوم بنقل هاي
التكنولوجيا يعني الى حد ما في في حكم
لهاي التكنولوجيا يعني معظم الدول العربيه
لديها مصانع انتاج خلايا شمسيه ولكن هي
عباره عن خلايا تجميع
السيليكون الاساس اللي يتم تصنيعه في
مصانع عديده بدول العالم بالصين وامريكا
وباوروبا ولكن انه احنا لازم نفتقر الى
هذه التكنولوجيا كذلك نفس الامر بالنسبه
لطاقه الرياح يعني احنا محطات الرياح كلنا
نستور الخارج التربينات تستورد من الخارج
وبالتالي انه يعني لا يزال عنا العائقين
الاساسيات اللي هي نقل التكنولوجيا سواء
المنطقه العربيه ودول العالم الاخرى موضوع
كذلك انه التخزين الطاقه المتجدده حتى
يزداد نسبه انتشارها يعني من هي الدول
الرائده في الغرب او في الشرق التي يمكن
للدول العربيه ان تعتمد عليها في تاسيس
هذه البنيه التحتيه يعني اذا حكينا احنا
مثلا بالنسبه لطاقه الرياح هناك الدول
الاوروبيه والصين والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بصراحه هذه الدول الرائده
وحاليا الصين هي تقود العالم في موضوع انه
انتاج تربينات الرياح وتركيبها حتى
تركيبها داخل الصين بالنسبه للطاقه
الشمسيه يعني كانت المانيا بصراحه من
الدول الرائده جدا ولكن مع دخول الصين قبل
عشر سنوات او 15 سنه على خط الانتاج
وانتقال المصالح الى الصين ورخص الانتاج
بالصين طبعا معظم المصانع اللي هي خلينا
نحكي الاوروبيه والامريكيه لم تستطع ان
تنافس يعني وبالتالي ان اصبح السوق معظمه
حاليا بيد بيد الصين فهي التكنولوجي
موجوده لدى الصين اليابان امريكا واوروبا
معظمهم لديهم هذه التكنولوجيا واحنا يعني
فعلا لزياده فرص العمل وزياده فعلا ان
تقليل البطاله بحاجه انه احنا نقوم بتصنيع
هذه بصراحه المنتجات وتركيبها مش فقط
استيرادها وانه بصراحه انه تركيبها لانه
ماديا مش كثير بتكون بصراحه مجديه احيانا
لنرى مع الدكتور حسين باسي فيما يتعلق
بمدينه اليوم السعوديه
يعني من يطلع على هذا المشروع يلاحظ انه
لدي تصور مختلف تماما عن الطبيعه
التقليديه لانشاء المدن والمناطق الجديده
بمعنى انه الان هناك طموح لجعل اليوم
مشغله بنسبه 100% بالطاقه المتجدده هل
يمكن ان يكون فعلا هذا نموذج ملهم سواء
للمملكه او لبقيه الدول من خلال انجاح هذه
التجربه
صحيح طبعا احنا لما عند الحديث عنهم في
الحديث يكون عن نظام متكامل هي ليست فقط
عمليه انتاج الطاقه وانما ايضا تعتمد على
اسستن او عمليه اللي هو الاستدامه
المتواجده في نيو نيوم هو فعلا نموذج رائع
جدا من حيث عمليه توليد الكهرباء ومن حيث
عمليه استهلاك الكهرباء فنعم في اذا كان
الاستهلاك يعني بطريقه ذات كفاءه عاليه
فيكون الانتاج سهل على هذه المصادر التي
تعتمد على الطاقه المتجدده وعنها عمليه
تخزينها لانه زي ما تفضل
الضيوف الكرام في بعض النقاط اللي هي
عمليه تخزين الطاقه او البطاريه
انظمه تخزين الطاقه في الاوقات يكون فيها
الحاجه الى الطاقه عاليه ولكن توفيرها
يكون هناك فيه اشكاليه يتم الاعتماد على
هذه الوحدات التخزين اليوم هو عن نظام
متكامل يعتمد على ليس فقط توليد الطاقه من
الطاقه المتجدده وهي عباره عن مئه في
المئه وانما ايضا على استبدال الطاقه من
مصادرها الرئيسيه على سبيل المثال
الاستدامه التي يجب توفرها في نظام يوم
تعتمد على الاناره الطبيعيه في اماكن
كثيره ففي فتره النهار يتم الاعتماد على
اناره الشمس بطريقه
تغني عن استخدام الكثير من الاناره
الصناعيه كالمصابيح والاض واللد وغيرها من
هذه التكنولوجيا فلذلك نعم نيوم هو مثال
قادر على وضع قوانين جديده في توليد
الكهرباء والطاقه وفي استخدامها
واستهلاكها في نفس الوقت
وعندما نتحدث سيد عزيز رباح في الرباط
عندما نتحدث عن هذه الخطط الموجوده لدى
الكثير من الدول العربيه اذا اردنا ان
نتوقف قليلا عند ابرز العراقيل التي ربما
تحول دون ان تسير هذه الامور بشكل جيد
وبوتيره
معقوله ما هي ابرز هذه العراقيل
اذا سمحت يعني بايجاز فيما سبق حول موضوع
التكنولوجيا جميع ان نعلم ان اليوم الصراع
في العالم حول قضايا
معروفه صراع على التكنولوجيا وعلى الدواء
على الماء على الطاقه او على الغداء
فاعتقد انه سيستمر هذا الصراع لكن هناك
فرصه للدول العربيه هو عندها قدره تفاوضيه
كبيره جدا اليوم لا يمكن ان نسمح بان
تستغل معادننا بالطريقه المتعارف عليها
اليوم العالم كله خاصه العالم الناميه
ابدا بافريقيا كلهم الان يتفاوضون من اجل
ان تخلق القيمه المضافه داخل الدول التي
توجد فيها هذه المعادن ولذلك اعتقد العالم
سيحتاج الى المعادن العربيه الى معادن
الدول الناميه وبالتالي هذه فرصه للتفاوض
حول على توطين صناعات تكنولوجيه متقدمه في
كافه المجالات ليس فقط مجال الطاقه بل حتى
في مجال الصناعات الاخرى وهذه فرصه
تاريخيه بالنسبه للدول العربيه الموضوع
فيما يتعلق بالعراقيل الممكنه دعني اقول
اولا
اهم شيء هي هذه قضيه الحوكمه التي اشرتم
اليها في السابق واعتقد ان هذه لابد ان
تعى احظى بعنايه خاصه على سبيل المثال
تجربتنا نحن في المغرب ان جلاله الملك
حفظه الله كاعلى سلطه في البلاد يشرف
شخصيا على مجموعه من الاستراتيجيات وعلى
راسها طبعا هذه الاستراتيجيه الطاقيه هناك
اجتماعات دوريه لمتابعه مدى الانجاز ومدى
الالتزام وتتخذ القرارات يعني التي تجود
يعني مسار يعني تنزيل هذه الاستراتيجيه
واحيانا تتخذ قرارات يعني حتى ضد من يعرقل
هذه الامر الثاني انا اعتقد اهم شيء يجب
ان تنتبه الى الدول العربيه في اطار
الشراكه بين القطاع العام والقطاع الخاص
هي ان تقرا العقود بان هذه العقود هي عقود
معقده يعني ملف ملفات كبيره لهذه العقود
واحيانا تكون بعض الجمل في هذه العقود قد
لا تكن عندنا خبراء لذلك نحن نحتاج الى
خبره قانونيه عاليه جدا لكي تكون هذه
العقود في صالح دولنا لان هذا الاستثمار
الخاص في اطار الشراكه بين القطاع العام
والقطاع الخاص يضمن ثلاثي اولا يضمن ربحيه
هذا المستثمر لان ليس هناك مستثمر سيقوم
بعمل خيري يريد ان يربح ينظما ايضا تامين
الطاقه للبلد يعني الامن الطاقي ومداخيل
للدوله طبعا يعني ميزانيه الدوله ثم ايضا
نضمن يعني
وصول المواطن لهذه الطاقه بجوده وبكلفه
متحكم فيها ولذلك موضوع عقود هذا موضوع
اعتقد انه مهم مهم جدا الامر الثالث وهو
قد نجد نوع من التلكؤ لدى بعض القطاعات في
الالتزام بالتطبيق او باستعمال الطاقات
المتجدده يعني ما دام انه خاصه مثلا في
القطاع الانتاجي قطاع الانتاجي والقطاع
الصناعي قد نجد بعض المصانع بادرت ولكن
نجد مصانع كثيره لم تبادر لذلك انا اعتقد
ان هذه وخاصه ان الصناعه يعني حوالي كما
قلت ما بين 22% احيانا تصل 30% حسب حسب
الدول اظن انه بالامكان ان نفرض نوع من
الالتزام لدى القطاعات الانتاجيه لتطبيق
لاستعمال الطاقات المتجدده ولا سيما ان
فيه تخفيض للكلفه ونحن نريد ان نخفض كلفه
الانتاج الصناعي ثم ايضا حتى نتجاوز ونحن
نصبر يعني نتجاوز يعني الاجراءات الضريبيه
التي تتخذ ضد الدول التي لا تستعمل
الطاقات النظيفه لذلك انا اعتقد هذه اهم
تحديات واهم عراقيل اخر نقطه يمكن ان
نتحدث عنها وقد لا ينتبه لها الكثيرون وهو
الجانب البيئي صحيح ان الطاقات المتجدده
تعالج القضايا البيئيه يعني سواء داخل
المدن او خارج المدن في الانتاج او حتى في
النقل حتى داخل المدن لان المدن تسبب الان
70% من التلوث في العالم نظرا لان هي
الحاضنه لاغلب الانشطه ولكن انا اعتقد انه
حتى الطاقات المتجدده في حد ذاتها هي ايضا
فيها اشكالات يجب ان يفكر فيها في
المستقبل اليوم مخلفه الطاقه الالواح
الشمسيه الريحيه وغيرها يجب ان يفكر فيها
لانها ستشكل ايضا عبئا في المستقبل
بالنسبه للعالم والان هناك حديث حول هذا
الموضوع طبعا هذه بعض ملامح العراقيل
والاشكالات التي يمكن ان تطرح يعني
بالنسبه للدول العربيه ولكن انا متفائل
لان هناك جيل سياسي جيل اداري جي
الاقتصادي جيل التكنولوجي هناك استراتيجيه
يؤمن بالتحول يعني في كافه المجالات
الطاقي والرقمي وغيره من اجل مستقبل افضل
للدول العربيه
ارتباطا تحديدا بهذا الكلام للسيد رباح هل
ربما نحن الان في غمره هذا الحماسه هذه
الحماسه للطاقه المتجدده قد لا نكون
قادرين على التوقف عند عيوبها اشار الى
اننا قد نكتشف لها عيوب في الفتره المقبله
هل هل بدل هل بدات بعض العيوب تتراءوى
علينا ان نهتم بها من الان يعني انا لا
اريد ان اسميها عيوبا ولكن فعلا هناك بعض
المحاذير وبعض القضايا يجب التعامل من
البدايه على سيد مثال الطاقه الشمسيه
الالواح الشمسيه لها فتره 25 سنه بعد 25
سنه انت يعني اين ستذهب بهذه الالواح وهذه
ستشكل
الافتراضي 25 سنه انه هي كل سنه تقل
كفاءتها ففعلا معظم الابحاث والدراسات
تقول انه بعد 25 سنه يعني سيتم انه
استبدالها او تغييرها هلا اعاده تدويرها
ممكن تمام هلا فعلا بدات العديد من الدول
الغربيه في عمل انه مصانع لاعاده تدوير
الالواح الشمسيه وبالتالي انه الاستفاده
من السيليكون الاستفاده من المكونات
الموجوده فيها الدول العربيه للاسف صراحه
لم يعني لم تقوم باي عمليه فيها في هذا
المجال يعني احنا بدانا في مشاريع طاقه
متجدد ولكن انه بدات تواجهنا بعض المشاكل
موضوع وهذا احنا ما نعمل عليه حاليا متى
على موضوع الصيانه موضوع انه تاهيل
مهندسين وف انهم يستطيع ان يتعاملوا مع
المشاكل التي تطرا من مواضيع الطاقه
المتجدده يعني احنا بحاجه للاعداد له مثلا
كيف يمكن ان تعالج يعني تعالج حاليا انه
بصراحه انه يعني في البدايه تم التركيز
انه على انه تخريج كفاءات مهندسين وفنيين
يستطيعون تصاميم
الخلايا الشمسيه تصاميم المشاريع الشمسيه
الى اخره هلا انه احنا فعلا بدانا في
برامج الصيانه برامج كيفيه انه نعمل صيانه
لمشاريع الطاقه المتجدده وان يتم انشاء
اجيال بصراحه فنيين متدربين بهذا المجال
من خلال طبعا العديد من البرامج التدريب
المهني والبرامج الدراسيه الموضوع الاخر
اللي هو اعاده التدوير وبالتالي يعني يجب
علينا التفكير جليا وخاصه معظم الدول
العربيه لديها مشاريع ضخمه حاليا من
الطاقه الشمسيه هي بحاجه فعلا انه يتم
انشاء هاي المصانع لاجل التدوير للمحافظه
على البيئه وان لا تكون يعني مكبات
للنفايات وان يتم الاستفاده من هاي
المكونات واعاده مره اخرى فهي يعني في بعض
المحاذير الاخرى يعني احنا بالنسبه للطاقه
المتجدده اللي هي ان احيانا بحاجه الى
مساحات واسعه والحمد لله احنا في الوطن
العربي انا لدينا مساحات واسعه ممكن انه
يتم الاستفاده منها
موضوع اللي هي انا ذكرته موضوع اللي هي
عمليه انه احنا بحاجه انه الى التخزين هل
انا استخدم بطاريات هل استخدم طاقه مائيه
انه يتم انه الطاقه الشمسيه عندما او
الطاقه الرياح فائضه عندي يتم انه يطخ
المياه الارتفاعات علويه ولا ما نحتاجها
بتم انه تدوير المياه حاليا انه عندنا
موضوع جديد على الوطن العربي وعلى العالم
اللي هو الهيدروجين الاخضر الهيدروجين
الاخضر اللي هو فعلا انه استخدام الطاقه
المتجدده
في الاردن في عنا في مدينه العقبه مشروع
دراسه جدوى اقتصاديه في المغرب في عمان في
مصر مصر وقعت مجموعه من الاتفاقيات معظم
الدول العربيه ماشيه في موضوع اللي هو
انتاج
الهيدروجين الاخضر هو عباره عن طاقه نظيفه
مصدرها طاقه متجدد ويكون كالوقود كالغاز
انه فعلا ممكن استخدامه حاليا انه
الدراسات عديده انه استخدام السفن طاقه
السفن تكون من الهيدروجين الطائرات النقل
وبالتالي يعني في في مواضيع عديده احنا
يتوجب علينا في الوطن العربي العمل عليها
وفعلا بناء القدرات في هذا المجال شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور احمد السلايمه شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من جده الدكتور حسين باسي شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من الرباط الدكتور السيد عزيز
رباح بهذا المشاهد الكرام نكون قد وصلنا
الى نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد باذن
الله تعالى الاسبوع المقبل في امان الله
[موسيقى]